gestern abend landete die dragon
raumkapsel der sasics wieder sicher im
golf von mexiko der drache ist gelandet
pünktlich um 20 uhr 48 landeten die
beiden nase raumfahrer bopfingen und da
curly wieder auf der erde
[Applaus]
das besondere zum ersten mal seit den
apollo zeiten in den 70er jahren kam es
zu einer wasserlandung die kapsel
endeavour wurde von vier fallschirmen
abgebremst kam vor der küste floridas
nahe der stadt pensacola im golf von
mexiko auf schon knapp zehn minuten
später erreichten mehrere boote die
kapsel
gegen 21 uhr 17 wurde sie aus dem wasser
gehoben
die erfolgreiche mission der crew dragon
ist ein meilenstein für die us-raumfahrt
die seit 2011 auf russische raketen
angewiesen war entsprechend groß wurde
sie gefeiert als die beiden weltraum
veteranen am 30 mai richtung iss
geschickt worden
[Musik]
die mission mit dem code-namen dem o2
verlief faszinierend und komplett
pannenfrei für die raumfahrt ist nun
eine neue ära angebrochen in der
privatfirmen wie spacex den transport
von raumfahrern ins all übernehmen und
natürlich für elon musk selbst ist es
der größte erfolg seiner so schillernden
laufbahn
ich glaube darauf kann die ganze welt
ein stück weit stolz sein und es als
errungenschaft der menschheit betrachtet
wir befinden uns aktuell in schwierigen
zeiten mit wenigen schönen nachrichten
und deshalb ist das für alle menschen
auf der ganzen welt eine gute sache 2002
hatte er sex gegründet damals wurde er
noch für verrückt gehalten jetzt hat
elon musk demonstriert dass er sicher
astronauten ins all befördern kann und
sie auch wieder sicher zur erde
zurückholen kann ein persönlicher
triumph für elon musk und natürlich auch
große erleichterung bei der nasa die
viel riskiert hat in dem sie praktisch
den transport von raumfahrern
outgesourced hat an privatfirmen wie sp6
dass die mission control der ahl firma
von elon musk zeigte am ende dann sogar
ein wenig humor ammann hieß die
raumfahrer willkommen zurück auf der
erde und sagte dann danke dass sie mit
spacex geflogen sind die nächste mission
von spacex im dienste der nasa ist
geplant für das nächste frühjahr wenn
über diesem wasserlandung möchte ich
jetzt sprechen mit professor ulrich
walter von der tu münchen mir nun
zugeschaltet guten morgen frau heute sie
waren selber auch bereits auf der iss
die frage also warum genau hat man sich
jetzt für eine wasserlandung entschieden
ist diese komplizierte es gab es
immerhin seit den 70er jahren ja nicht
mehr
ja zunächst im schönen guten morgen frau
damals flogen wir mit dem shuttle und
der shuttle kann auf einer landebahn
landen so ist es konstruiert aber
kapseln können sich auf einer landebahn
landen sondern entweder nur auf dem land
so wie es die busse machen mit ihrer
sojus-kapsel dazu braucht man allerdings
eine riesen gebiet wie in kasachstan das
ist ein städten gebiet 1000 mal 1000
kilometer groß oder halt im wasser und
die amerikaner haben die usa da gibt es
keine große wüste keine stöcke und
deswegen habe sich dafür entschieden im
wasser zu landen und auch da gibt es
viel platz
das heißt es ist jetzt aber nicht direkt
komplizierte am wasser zu landen als
jetzt in der steppe wie die russen das
tor
im gegenteil es ist leichter also sie
sehen das ja bei apollo die ganze gemini
apollo zeit da wurde nur im wasser
gelandet das haben die amerikaner gut im
griff sie wissen wie das geht man muss
nur aufpassen dass die kapsel dann
irgendwie sich nicht mit wasser füllte
dann abtaucht auch das ist in der
polizei passiert aber das hat man
heutzutage gut im griff
das haben wir gerade in dem beitrag
gehört ele maskat jetzt also bewiesen
dass er menschen ins all schicken kann
und auch sicher wieder zurückholen kann
was bedeutet das vor allem für die nasa
wenn der weltraum jetzt immer mehr
kommen letzten kommunalisiert wird
kommerzialisiert wird es ist noch früh
am morgen
es ist wirklich so also die raumfahrt
befindet sich im augenblick in einem
gigantischen umbruch da gibt es
privatpersonen die ihre maske der hat
etwa 10 milliarden dollar seines geldes
in dieses unternehmen reingesteckt das
ist für ihn eine herzensangelegenheit er
will in die geschichte der menschheit
eingehen als derjenige der die
menschheit zum mars gebracht hat für ihn
ist das was wir gerade gesehen haben nur
ein erster schritt
und er hat viel geld investiert und da
gibt es noch andere private unternehmen
die jetzt auch noch in den weltraum
gehen die nasa kauft sich bei denen ein
um plätze für den für den flug zur
raumstation zum zu bekommen das
privatunternehmen werden jetzt in
zukunft die raumstation finanz nicht
finanzieren aber doch mit transport
besorgen sowohl mit personen also
astronauten als auch mit cargo also mit
fracht all das wird kommerzialisiert
werden und da bleibt einfach die frage
wozu brauchen eigentlich noch die nasa